all right i'm gonna try and do this
video with my ipad normally i do it with
my iphone but the uh
the iphone seems to have given up the
ghost so it's my last night here in la
vie
i've had a fabulous experience here i've
enjoyed it the people are super friendly
i've improved my ukrainian just came
back with my wife we were in the
carpathian mountains we were down in
cherniv sea which is a beautiful city
and um
just come away with a great positive
feeling about ukraine
one thing about my and of course
the first evening when i had just
arrived here
of course i was lost i didn't know the
streets of the city and now i know the
city quite well and i think that's a bit
like language learning when we first
started out everything seems strange and
just with
regular exposure we get a better sense
of the um of the language behind me is
this cherry tea the tree that people
like to take their pictures in front of
but one thing i want to talk about is
i had my last lesson with solomia my
teacher and i made the usual mistakes in
case endings and so she corrected me and
then she sort of had me decline certain
mounds
and it made me very uh
you know more self-conscious and made me
feel that my goal of reasonable fluency
in ukrainian was getting further and
further away
and
you know and then we got over that and
we started talking about and again and
we got wrapped up in our whatever the
subject of our conversation was and i i
felt myself getting better again and it
made me realize that a lot of this error
correction or deliberate study of things
uh can have the the effect of making us
more self-conscious and inhibiting us uh
in driving around ukraine with ukrainian
business contact who spoke english he
was constantly saying you know how he
has to improve and he makes so many
mistakes
hey
okay come here
i make here is conor clyne i made my
fair farewell video here awesome the
popeye i thought he was just a friendly
ukrainian i actually lived just here
right so you were actually filming
outside my apartment give me a couple of
minutes so i come over and join you
steve
the man the man there we go okay so the
point i wanted to make
is that um you know he's always worried
about the mistakes he's making
um i don't notice him making mistakes
and and my teacher got me thinking about
the mistakes that i make and it made me
more inhibited and made me speak worse
and once we got back into actually just
speaking and communicating i started
doing better again and i think there's a
lesson there and i'm going to tell my
teacher
don't do that
i can always look up the declension
table but we just want to speak and
you've got to get me sort of
you know grease the wheel so that i
start really speaking and on that basis
in the end i'm going to do better i'm
going to communicate better and my
language will improve so there you have
it it's our last night in la vie i'll
miss it tremendously and the next video
will be from vancouver bye for now
[Music]
you